hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Game of Thrones video for
favorite debunked theories like the most
crazy ridiculous theories that have
since been debunked so just careful for
spoilers for everything that the TV show
has done so far because we're so deep
into the break before Game of Thrones
season 7 gets here I'm going to be doing
a lot of fun Theory videos like this
this is more about the craziest theories
but be sure to subscribe to get
everything and make sure you enable
alerts YouTube's doing some weird stuff
right now so you might not see
everything so when you subscribe just
make sure that the Bell is grayed out so
crazy game of Thrones theories number 10
a lot of you have heard the r plus l
equals j theory jon snow is the son of
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna stark so
there's a counter theory to that that
john is secretly the son of Ned Stark
and Lyanna Stark and there was a
twincest situation which just makes your
head spin because we know sometime after
the tourney of Harrenhal Rhaegar
absconded with Lyanna stark seemingly
capturing her so it set off the chain of
events that led to Robert's rebellion
between that time in the end of Robert's
rebellion when Ned Stark finally found
Liana in the Tower of joy in this you
know pool of blood more than a year had
passed meaning that she could not have
been pregnant by Ned Stark
so first big theory debunked and you
didn't even need to watch season six to
do it you literally could have just
looked at the timeline one of the things
that Martin does in the books is spell
dates out so he gives you the clues you
need to parse the timeline so even
though the series has not officially
confirmed R plus L equals J it is
definitely not n plus L equals J thank
God number 9 there are a lot of theories
about people secretly being other people
you're not a character in Game of
Thrones until you might secretly be
another character in disguise so there
was a theory that Benjen stark was
secretly Daario and had gone to make a
new life in the east like he just
completely bailed on the watch now we
know the TV show is just a little
different from the books and what the TV
show has done is use benjin as cold
hands from the books cold hands is sort
of like the
half turned white Walker who still has a
little bit of his mind left and is able
to help bran Stark as he's going to see
the last green seer so even though the
show is used Benjen in a slightly
different way from the books Martin has
said that he will eventually pop back up
again meaning that Dario has to be
another character next big one
number 8 Roose Bolton is actually a half
human half other skin-changer who has
used the faces of the people he's flayed
house Bolton the flayed man to survive
for a long time in disguise so he's an
extremely long-lived person just
masquerading as this Lord of Westeros so
what this is is kind of like a version
of Arya walking around changing her face
killing the people on her list as we saw
that she started to do at the end of
season six in the idea that there was
something more sinister behind Roose
Bolton's evil but as we know from the TV
show from the books Roose is just a
terrible terrible person the story that
he told Ramsay about his mother was
horrifying how he basically raped her
killed the woman's husband then when she
came back later with the baby Ramsay
almost decided to kill him but took him
in out of the kindness of his heart what
a charitable person it almost made you
feel a little bad for Ramsay after that
of course Ramsay himself is a very
terrible person the show did heighten
him just a little bit he's a terrible
person in the books but he's not quite
as big a character as he was on the TV
show it's just that there's fewer
characters on the TV show so it's
seemingly focused on him more but you've
heard about the prophecy the three heads
of the Dragon you know number seven
there was a theory this is so great that
the three heads of the Dragon were
Samwell Tarly mance rayder and Hodor
so the three heads of the Dragon are
these mythical people that get tied up
in the prophecy of the prince who was
promised and will serve as something of
like a last defense against the White
Walkers and the new long night
Rhaegar spoke the prophecy Daenerys
heard it when she was in the house of
the undying they didn't quite do it on
the TV show it's a much bigger scene in
the books but effectively what the show
has
forward so far says that Daenerys John
Snow and Tyrion will probably be the
three heads of the Dragon now that might
be a slight change from the books but
most of the evidence is pointing towards
them especially scenes like this where
Tyrion talks about how much he wanted a
dragon as a child in now the Dragons
seemingly trust him so there's a whole
bunch of other stuff that goes into
dragon riding dragon bonding but the
three heads of the Dragon is mostly a
prophecy that talks about the three most
important people in the war for the dawn
so Samwell still a very critical
character for learning important
information on fighting White Walkers
probably not going to be writing any
dragons any time soon the next one
number six is really good one to the
Arya Fight Club theory that she imagined
the wave in her head there was actually
this is one of my more favorite debunked
theories but since they wrapped season
six the actors the producers the people
that were actually there filming those
scenes said no you know we weren't doing
any crazy Fight Club stuff this was arya
just fighting someone who hated her who
just also happened to be from Westeros
the wave actually came from a fairly
similar background to Arya she was
originally born into one of the lesser
noble houses not nearly as great a house
as House Stark but through violent means
found herself going to the east at the
house of black and white to become a
faceless person so her main problem with
Arya the main reason why she was
fighting her so much was because she
felt she was not committed fully
committed to their cause and it's
actually true Arya did decide to go back
to Westeros so there are actually some
pretty good behind-the-scenes theories
about why George R Martin wrote that
storyline when they could have had Arya
trained in Westeros but that's like a
whole other video game of Thrones
abandoned plot lines and things that
change from George RR Martin's original
outline next one also really good one
number five Sansa was pregnant with
Ramsay's baby this has actually been
confirmed by actors more recently where
they have reiterated no Sansa is not
pregnant the whole reason this got
started was because when they were
promoting season six they released a
couple photos in Sansa
a dress that was just really bulky like
the winter coat that she escaped in when
she and Theon were running from Ramsay's
dogs she looked like she had this bulge
in her dress so people thought that
might mean that she's pregnant but the
timeline didn't work out and it was just
a really WTF twist the people were
hoping were true just because the show
had been piling on Sansa so much since
season 5 with this whole Ramsay
storyline let's see how much we can drag
her through the mud and even when he met
his untimely end
at the mouths of his own dogs in said to
Sansa some of me is inside of you like
he implied that there was some of him
that would live on in her he was mostly
talking about the seed of evil but some
people double down on the pregnant Sansa
theory and felt like this meant that she
actually had like a literal baby literal
Ramsay seed growing inside of her but
since then the actors have confirmed
this is not the case so no pregnant
Sansa next one number four Martin is a
big Tolkien fan as we all are but some
people believe that Westeros a Song of
Ice and Fire
the world itself is just the world of
The Lord of the Rings stories
middle-earth 2,000 years after the
events of Lord of the Rings so it's
crazy but some people did believe that A
Song of Ice and Fire really was talking
fanfic but typically what people point
to when they say why a Song of Ice and
Fire
is so much better than other fantasy
literature is that it doesn't fall into
the tropes of recycling talking so
Martin went out of his way to not do
talking so it's like the complete
opposite but some people looking at the
map and feeling that both of the series
that pull from real-life events like a
lot of Game of Thrones is based on
real-life events in and around Western
Europe so is talking so they must be the
same planet but it's just another big
theory that has been debunked number
three we know that time travel exists a
form of time travel because bran is the
last green sphere now and he can use the
weirwoods to astral project himself into
the past the show has played a little
fast and loose with whether or not he
can directly affect the past seemingly
Ned Stark hears something when
brand calls out to him but that's mostly
them messing with us a little bit there
is a time-travel theory that does not
involve brand there was a very well
thought out but misguided theory the
Tyrian is secretly the son of Khal Drogo
in Daenerys thanks to blood magic now it
just sounds so crazy that already you
kind of dismiss it but it was so well
thought out and so crazy people were
fascinated with the idea but we know
that Meera masters blood magic
effectively traded Ragle her baby for
Drogo who came back in this sort of half
life half death state and ended up dying
again so that in and of itself became
the catalyst for the hatching of her
Dragon's Blood pays for blood
so really the blood magic just led to
the hatching of her dragons that was
really all that was about but even when
you get into crazy blood magic Tyrians
birth was witnessed by other people just
in the way that Daenerys does birth was
witnessed by people so number two
slightly more plausible but still pretty
ridiculous Ned Stark secretly a warg
left his body and is still alive out
there somewhere today but the problem
with that is that Ned Stark's death is
this huge catalyst for the story so it
was necessary that he die and it would
be a big middle finger to take that back
this late in the game and the reason why
is just a little bit better in terms of
crazy theories that have been debunked
is that martin has confirmed that all
the stark children and Ned start to have
wolf dreams that does not mean that
they're all wargs it just means they
have the potential to become wargs if
they develop the ability but in most of
them it goes on practiced especially
someone like Ned Stark so even if he did
have wolf dreams and he could have Ward
had he been a really badass warg in that
moment he was not and ended up dying but
Nymeria in ghosts are still alive so
there's still people that could work
into their direwolves in the future if
they want to go that direction but
number one this is actually like a
really good crazy theory this is one of
my favorites so far so there was a
theory that Hodor was secretly the great
other controlling the White Walkers so
this theory popped up sometime before
or we saw that season six episode where
we learned the origin of hoe doors name
but as important as his character was
he's largely this Monday in person who
just helps out and winds up tied up in
saving brand so that he can go on and do
the things that he needs to do so very
critical very heartbreaking ending but
he's not meant to be anything more than
the person who helps brand get away from
the night king that it goes all the way
back in that big time loop so just the
mechanics of what actually happened on
the show like the truth made people's
heads spin so theories like this
actually don't sound that crazy but when
you actually think about it
Hodor secretly being the night king who
himself was chasing them down just
sounds completely ridiculous so let me
know in the comments what is your
favorite craziest game of Thrones theory
that has been debunked since the series
started it could be a book theory it
could be a TV show theory there are so
many bad ones out there that are so much
fun to read later on like I didn't
include it on the list but there was the
theory that Varys was really a merman
because he was not afraid of the water
which already just sounds ridiculous so
that's how most of these debunked
theories go they have like a little bit
of truth to them because of some moment
that happens or a character exchange but
what's going to happen is is I'll do
some more Theory videos in the next
couple of weeks for theories that I
actually think are true and do have a
basis in reality but if there are
special theories or even prophecies that
you guys want me to do longer videos
about just let me know in the comments
and I'll say congratulations to this
week's giveaway winner 7:29 drew you win
a $20 Amazon gift card please private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details in a
new round of the giveaway starts now all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video so just a reminder just because
YouTube is being weird right now make
sure you enable alerts like make sure
that bell is grayed out and actually
this avatar reminds me Rick and Morty's
season 3 is getting ready to get started
I will be doing videos for it the first
video will drop in the next week so
Walking Dead coming later tonight Rick
and Morty coming later this week if you
guys haven't seen it it's one of the
best new animated series in the last
couple of years that I started watching
what you guys wait for that to post you
can click here for that season seven
teaser trailer and you can click here
for my season seven predictions thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you